by the end of the year i had a
spreadsheet of
every topic that most black comics
nationally were discussing and i just
went okay cool
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
so let's get right into what i think you
do as well as anybody in the world which
is why we're so happy to have you here
from a content creation standpoint from
a creative standpoint
how do you personally as a human like
think about that how did you
come you know what kind of process
even at a child to back to being four
did you have comedy around the house
did it come natural were you distracting
teachers in third grade like
what was your early process of what has
become your professional process
uh comedy was escapism for me i wasn't
in the same school system for more than
two years until high school
so it was the constant re-acclimation
to the social scenes and circles of
people around birmingham
and like i would take the radio my
father
uh was in journalism and so i would
follow him to speaking engagements and
stuff like that
and you know he was he was a lot more
working he worked at me in terms of his
content and what he spoke for and what
he fought for
but the oration part of it i'm sure i
got from him
um i'd say the biggest the first big
deal was in the sixth grade
um i decided to make my own comic book i
was obsessed with comic strips
we read the newspaper as a family every
sunday morning that was our thing we
sit the paper down and pull it apart
like a turkey and everybody would read a
different section
and so you know i was into marmaduke and
garfield
and calvin and hobbes the whole run and
i drew my own comic book
and then i would charge students 50
cents to read it
and then you had to bring it back it was
like a one comic book blockbuster
and i think that was my first hustle
the concept of a copy machine and a
stapler just
didn't you missed it you missed it i was
like no
this is the only one you have to give it
back on thursday
because of getting ice cream money right
right
on the record who tried to not bring it
back on time
in the history of this business uh
everybody
there was a guy trey mcclure we're
friends now so i can call him out by
school
he held on to mr goose a little longer
than he should
love tray i know this is going to get
back to you because alabama likes to
gossip
um so for me that was kind of where you
know
being funny started and high school was
really where things
started moving i got cut from my high
school baseball team my freshman year
but i wanted to learn
and see well if i suck what are they
doing right
so i volunteered to be the bat boy
equipment manager whatever you want to
call it
and i just trailed the varsity kids
around for a whole season
and they did the food fundraisers where
you sell the chips to raise money to pay
for the uniform
and i outsold everyone in the school
interesting so
that was when you start noticing
how you need to build relationships and
sometimes it's not what you're selling
it's who you are
the product becomes secondary uh to a
greater degree
uh there's a gentleman that my father
worked for named aj gaston who was one
of the first black millionaires
and a.g gaston had a mantra it was
called
find a need and fulfill it and so
that always stuck with me and to bring
you to the present
comedically and where content creation
is concerned for me it's always been
about
seeing all right what is out there
and is there a way to make that feel
like something that's already happening
now i sold a project to comedy central
that we ended up shooting a pilot for
we're still in development uh and it's
about a probation officer and it's about
a probation officer and his relationship
with his client
and to kind of show a different side of
what law enforcement is probation
is law enforcement it's closer to social
work
on the spectrum of you know kicking ass
but it is law enforcement and
when you really boil the show down to a
lot of degrees there's a procedural
element to it but so it feels like
something you've seen before but it's
about a world that you know absolutely
nothing about and i think there's
a value in being unique and for me that
came
i got turned i guess i guess when i
think about it now all my
best moments came from when i was
rejected bt
passed on me for comic view for one year
in 2002
so much like baseball okay y'all didn't
pick me who did you pick
let's see what they did and i stepped
for an entire season to watch comic view
it's like 40 episodes six comics an
episode
and i just catalogued every topic that
was breached on the show
interesting and i just kept a list of
how many comedians talked about this
this this this and this
and by the end of the year i had a
spreadsheet of
every topic that most black comics
nationally were discussing and i just
went okay cool
i won't do any jokes about that so let's
just start there
and see if we can be something that
hasn't been heard before
it off that alone that should get me a
look it doesn't mean that my joke is
going to be the funniest but it will be
the most different
and if i can at least have that
advantage over you when it comes time to
pick tapes
then i think that's something worth
exploring and so right
right it's interesting you bring that up
because for me
and i'm a i talk a lot i produce so much
content
but so much of my strength and so much
of what i attribute
the good things that have happened to me
is about listening
and the story you just told is a really
strong
listening story the baseball story was a
strong listening story
do you feel like observation and
listening is foundational for you
yeah i think that's more important than
execution because you got to know where
to shoot you gotta know where to aim the
gun before you it's the inside it's a
strategy
yeah it's it's a sniper it's you're
sitting
for hours and hours taking in
information and deciding when is the
exact
proper moment you know to mount your
attack and so
for me it's definitely about listening
it's definitely about
assessing the marketplace seeing what's
being sold and seeing what's getting on
and then also trying to you know pull
away gretzky and be ahead of the puck
uh which is why kovitt is so interesting
to me
you know in terms of comedy creation and
content creation as a whole
because not only do you have a pandemic
where people are in pain and people are
going to be hurting and regardless if a
vaccine came tomorrow
there are going to be a lot of people
that are going to be dealing with a lot
of fiscal hurt a lot of emotional hurt i
lost an aunt in february so
i can't imagine what other people are
going through so
where there's pain there's laughter
there's an opportunity for a laugh
but you don't know how long and then on
top of that you have an election coming
on the back side of this and if you
think that
elections don't affect the type of
content that ends up on television
you're wrong
so it's about looking and figuring out
okay what can you picture what can you
create today
that's going to still have an impact no
matter
who wins in november and no matter what
people are going through you know the
thing that
the thing that's interesting now about
comedy chris rock said
um and i'm paraphrasing him but he
basically said
everything that i do is to convince
people to come see me live
everything in his portfolio was about
getting you to pay the 50
or whatever he's not 50 days probably
like 100 now but
to come see me live this is what come
see this movie
watch this tv show whatever well the
come see me live element
isn't really there right now for
comedians
and you don't know when that's going to
come back so
you have to do things that maintain
relevance so that when people
are ready to go back out and when people
have enough money
on a regular basis to go back out you
know because i'm not gonna sit here at
like what i do
is similar to the other people we're
gonna talk to today you know what i do
is a disposable income activity that can
hopefully alleviate a little bit of i'm
no different than a super wine
for me that's right it's a it's a
hundred percent escapism
it's a you know a hundred percent so you
know i think when people get back on
their feet and the unemployment dries up
the first thing you are thinking about
is coming to see some jokes from me
inside of a corona hut which is
which is what a comedy club is as far as
a low ceiling everybody together that's
a hut
that's the corona hut yeah you know so
it'll be a while so
it's about figuring out content and ways
to do things that keep you relevant and
keep you
on that note on that note because uh for
everybody's joining in
marketing for the now uh please tell us
what you think about this interview with
roy
uh these are about 15 minute blast so
before i lose right talk to me about the
call in digital show because i think as
i'm listening to you
it makes a whole lot of sense why you're
leaning in that direction
well because i feel like i feel like
when i get into too much detail about it
i feel like
it's an opportunity to unite people and
i see
where i see what's happening with a lot
of the zoom shows now like if you look
at
if you pick the game from the
from the beginning of quarantine where
you had a surge
and people becoming content creators so
there's fewer consumers of content
you know everybody's grabbing a
microphone i've gone to the camera
stores in new york and every time i try
to get
a camera component it's sold out or
there's a two week back order because
everybody's buying the same stuff now
um i think that we are all one and so i
did morning radio for 10 years and the
best part of morning radio was talking
to
the streets and i think that's the most
interactive way you know to go about
doing things and radio was a place where
i was able
to really build a lot of relationships
because i did print phone calls and so
with the print calls
i took print phone calls and this is pre
youtube this is 0203
so the only way you went viral was over
an email where
someone would send you an email and say
download this
and you would you would just download
random stuff to your laptop
and that's kind of how i was able to
kind of grow my comedy a little bit
and and so through that what i learned
was that
it's laughs that connect people so if we
can all laugh together then i think
there's something that's
there's something collective about that
and so when i look at the marketplace
when i find a need to fulfill i think
that the sense of collective
conversation
comedically um it's all you know most
comedy conversations are observational
they're voyeuristic
hey watch me talk to this person versus
hey
let's talk and i think that's the cool
thing about instagram live is that
is that you know people have a direct
line i think there's a way to kind of
set that up a little bit more
you know more formally uh real quick um
please like colton
what we did because i was having trouble
breaking into prank
phone calls in other markets and it just
goes back to finding a need and
fulfilling it
um i was having trouble breaking into
comedy clubs in certain markets because
i didn't have a television credit but i
think that most comedy clubs
value comedians that have media reach
and so the thing i knew about radio at
the time is that
most radio and smaller double a triple a
baseball cities
omaha syracuse's columbia missouri's of
the world
they're carrying jocks in the afternoon
or in the morning that are by themselves
or it's a two-person show so they don't
have a lot of content
we're only playing the prank calls in
birmingham they're not
and then they go in a vault forever so i
would contact djs in cities where i
wasn't getting booked at the comedy club
and mail them to print phone calls for
free
and just say play them and say my name i
don't care what you do with them after
that they're yours forever
and they would play them i'd let that
marinate for three months
then i would call the comedy club and
say hey i'm on the radio in your city
every week
you should probably book me at your club
and that's how i was able to expand my
reach comedically
and able to leverage those fans the one
mistake i made
was not having an email list
you didn't have the data do you
understand the data i would have had if
i had just been collecting emails since
oh
yeah that's the one
no but honestly i think the one thing
that you know that's fine
but i say this a lot to my team a lot of
people
value data very highly and the world
does and i do but
actual attention and and brand
really really gets underestimated and
the part you know i was listening very
intently
say my name and say it right and that's
it was exactly the punchline
of why you're sitting here today and i'm
really thrilled to be uh co-hosting this
uh day with you and i appreciate you and
thanks for
getting up early hey everybody on
youtube first of all thank you so much
so humbled for your time
i don't wanna watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out